[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]
[Гамбург,
Німеччина]
Кажуть, що Гамбург — це дорога у світ.
І багато митців,
які сюди приїжджали з України,
вони дійсно казали:
«Ти знаєш, Марушка, ми можемо тут
уявити сидіти й писати книгу
чи писати новий альбом».
Тобто щось є в місті, воно мене збирає.
Мене звати Юлія Марушко.
Для друзів — Марушка,
це теж моє мистецьке ім'я.
Дітки мене знають як Мишка Марушка.
Я — журналістка,
я — вальдорфська вчителька, художниця,
і зараз працюю я в садочку з найменшими дітьми.
У Гамбурзі живу з 2013 року,
сама — лучанка.
Волинянка.
[сміється]
Культура й освіта — два такі мої стержні,
і коли ти щось робиш,
ти можеш з радістю частину
своєї роботи віддавати і також приймати.
От часто питають: «А це діти малювали?»
Ні, це я! Для мене це — комплімент.
Ну якщо глянути, то так, діти — це та тема,
яка мене в Німеччину й покликала.
У 2012 році я поїхала в Кассель
(таке місто недалеко звідси),
аби навчатися на семінарі
для вальдорфського вчителя старшої школи,
тому що в мене така мрія:
створити таку школу в Луцьку.
І я якби думала, що за рік я вивчуся,
знайду спонсора й повернуся назад.
Але після навчання була практика в Гамбурзі.
Це якраз був 2013 рік, коли почався Майдан,
і тоді якби все змінилося, перевернулося.
Я познайомилася з усіма людьми на Майдані,
з людьми, які тут живуть.
Й одразу створила Артмайдан.
Тобто така прийшла ідея, що ми можемо показати
українську культуру в Гамбурзі.
Ми розтопили серця німців, це тривало так,
тому що тут така специфіка,
це не так швидко, як хотілося б,
але якість лишається.
І тому за такий короткий час свого існування
Артмайдан став однією з ініціатив,
яка робила на півночі Німеччини
найбільший такий рух,
від показів фільму українського в кінотеатрі,
концертів українських виконавців.
Для мене і для всього думаючого
світу Майдан став тим моментом,
моментом боротьби (і досі боротьби)
за людські права, проти корупції,
моментом такого пробудження.
Я вже тоді почала малювати,
вже тоді почала малювати перших
ще, яких можна було знайти,
перших вбитих на Майдані.
Усі вбиті з Волині в мене вийшли
тільки однією фарбою.
Були вони просто чорні.
Є один у мене портрет,
який намальований олійними крейдочками.
І це Роман Гурик.
Ой, він такий красивий!
Я просто дивилася постійно на нього, і це так є...
Я не знала, як його намалювати!
І прочитала я чи почула в інтерв'ю його мами,
що коли його вбили,
то в його рюкзаку знайшли кросівки
і фантики від цукерок.
Фантики від цукерок!
І тому це такі рожеві кольори пішли,
і це єдина така абсолютно якось...
Ну, портрет, який вибивається з цього ряду.
І все це я писала з 2014 до 2015 року,
отак справді вийшло воно все.
І саме ця серія «Сто акварелей. Небесна сотня» —
це була моя перша виставка в Гамбурзі.
Наша задача — не забувати тих людей,
які в мирний час,
просто посеред європейської столиці
були розстріляні.
Я от як зараз пам'ятаю,
у газеті «Der Spiegel» (Дзеркало) — редакція, до речі,
[знаходиться] в Гамбурзі —
була стаття про Сергія Нігояна.
І якби...
Ну я вже одразу відчула, що тут
починається вже щось страшне.
І ми тоді — просто група українців у Гамбурзі —
написали таку спонтанну акцію,
що ми йдемо просто до консульства.
Зараз всі ввечері збираємося.
Ми якось реагуємо на такі подразники.
Вдариш — зібралися,
а от працювати треба саме в момент «між».
Ми зараз знаходимося на вокзалі.
І саме на цьому місці була
перша демонстрація в Гамбурзі
на підтримку Євромайдану.
Демонстрації були в різних точках,
але цей було вибрано зі стратегічного плану
що дуже багато людей, як на вокзалі, ідуть,
зустрічаються і роз'їжджаються далі.
Це було дуже масово.
І так народився Артмайдан,
що мистецтво ми будемо показувати,
просто дійсно оцей обмін.
І ми якби звідси йшли дуже часто,
і ця вулиця виходить до консульства.
Артмайдан — це, в принципі, одна з тих ідей,
за які я досі стою,
що культура і мистецтво можуть змінити суспільство.
Ідемо ми зараз до Ральфа.
Режисер, який живе в Гамбурзі вже років тридцять,
з яким ми робимо німецько-український фільм
який називається «В Одесі».
Знімати будемо в Одесі,
але оскільки Гамбург дуже вже
схожий на Одесу, ну портом,
то деякі сцени на наш трейлер
ми знімали саме в Гамбурзі.
Бачу вже Ральфа,
який навіть у саду сидить і працює.
— [німецькою] Привіт, Ральфе! Привіт!
— Привіт!
Як справи?
Добре!
У Сан-Паулі...
[сміється]
Це...
Аааа!
Дивіться. [німецькою]
Тут написано: «В Одесі. Довгий трейлер».
[німецькою] Тож, розповідай, Ральфе.
— [німецькою] Ми працюємо разом уже три роки.
— [німецькою] Саме так.
[німецькою] Я режисер, а вона – драматургиня
та перекладачка цього фільму.
[німецькою] Ми хочемо зробити фільм,
власне повнометражний фільм,
[німецькою] про молоду журналістку, яка має в Одесі сім’ю,
[німецькою] і хоче зробити сюжет
про вуличних дітей в Одесі.
[німецькою] Їх там справді багато.
Я був кілька разів у Одесі.
[німецькою] І це є зовсім жахлива тема.
Це викрадення органів.
— [німецькою] Це художній фільм, який має підґрунтя…
— [німецькою] Правдиве.
[німецькою] Так, реальне підґрунтя.
Я особисто вдячна тобі за цю роботу.
[німецькою] Я переконана, що фільм ми зробимо швидко,
адже над ним працюють справжні професіонали.
[німецькою] Для України це дуже важливо,
але й для світу також.
[німецькою] І це найкраще дивитися в кіно.
[німецькою] Ральфе, я гадаю, ми можемо уже знімати новий серіал лише про наш фільм.
[німецькою] А зараз ти можеш подякувати
і попрощатися по-українськи.
[німецькою] О так, хвильку.
— Спасибі.
— [німецькою] Дуже добре.
— До...
— Побачення. [підказує]
[німецькою] Ми кажемо: «До побачення».
До поба... Дякую, дуже дякую!
Маю подарунок, радію!
— «In Odesa».
— Будь ласка!
[сміється]
Як це здорово щось робити з такого
альтруїстичного імпульсу, з мотиву!
Це така щирість у тому,
і такий, це можна назвати, студентський запал.
Але я за те, що неважливо, скільки тобі років якби,
у тебе ці сили й енергія не втрачалися.
Ми рік робили німецько-українські вечори,
вони називалися «Контрабанда».
І якби ідея була культурна програма і їжа, напої, їжа...
На перші вечори приходило десь двісті українців чи й не тільки.
У Гамбурзі немає жодного
українського ресторану.
Коли «Контрабанда» робила ці вечори,
цікаво, що ми їх організовували
в студії танго аргентинців.
— [іспанська] Хей, привіт!
— [іспанська] Ola!
[іспанською] Як справи?
[сміється]
[англійською] Ти в порядку?
[німецькою] Я нічого не... забула!
[сміється]
[німецькою] Тут ми робили «Контрабанду», так,
[німецькою] ці німецько-українські вечори?
[німецькою] І питання:
нам тут було дуже класно. А тобі як?
[німецькою] Україна, ти щось чув про Україну?
Чи як то було, раптом….
[німецькою] У будь-якому разі, культура інша,
ніж німецька культура, люди мають іншу ментальність.
[німецькою] Але тобі це подобалося, так?
[німецькою] Звичайно, звичайно.
[німецькою] Люди завжди живі, завжди хочуть
пропонувати щось нове, це люди, які не сидять і чекають.
[німецькою] Ми любимо танцювати.
[німецькою] Танцюють, і люди просять, якщо їм щось треба,
то вони питають не один раз, а п’ять разів.
[німецькою] Одного разу ви танцювали
українське танго, «Гуцулка Ксеня».
[німецькою] Це було класно. Величезне дякую, Матіасе.
Тут справді було суперово!
— [німецькою] Фріда Кало,  українська Фріда Кало.
— [німецькою] Українська Фріда Кало.
[іспанською] Дуже добре. [німецькою] То ще побачимося. [іспанською] До побачення.
За ці роки, що я тут... Коли ти кажеш, що ти з України,
от просто бачиш людей,
позитивна реакція, і це те, що нове.
Хоча українці без пісні — нікуди.
Навіть коли от в нас були демонстрації,
поліцаї, які приїжджали до нас,
їх було дуже мало завжди,
і вони казали: «А, це ж українці!
Після демонстрації вони всі лишаться і будуть мирно співати».
І це такі круті речі, ти розумієш:
«Ага, тебе так сприймають вже закордоном».
Зараз ми знаходимося біля Альстера,
це величезне озеро посеред міста.
Дуже красиво.
І тут генеральне українське консульство.
Коли почався Майдан, перше,
куди ми прийшли,
коли почався кривавий Майдан,
це було консульство.
І як і має бути для українців закордоном,
консульство стало місцем,
куди ми могли приходити, робити заходи.
І навіть
посадити дерево.
Це — верба Тарасова,
а Шевченко, як я багато пояснюю німцям
(хоча вони знають Шевченка, але футболіста),
що це для нас, як для вас Ґете.
Ми отут, просто біля консульства,
посадили цю вербичку,
якій вже чотири роки.
Ну, вона маленька, але потужна.
І верба, кажуть, це символ України,
вона дуже гнучка,
але має сильний стержень.
Це те, що хочеться й нам усім поважати.
Ти живеш тут, тіло тут,
серце там, голова — неясно де.
І напевно кожен, хто живе закордоном,
переживає такі моменти.
А тобі зараз з України: «Та! Тобі добре там сидіти!
Малюєш собі там, пхе!
Що ти взагалі знаєш,
що тут в Україні відбувається?»
І тут ще ж такі в тебе внутрішні
діалоги йдуть: «Покинула Україну!»
Що ти думаєш: «Ми люди світу!»
Кожен має право вибрати Берлін, Нью-Йорк,
Токіо, Луцьк, Великі Жмеринки
і сказати: «А чому я не можу тут пожити?»
Вільні школи — це перша складова
до розвитку вільної особистості.
Чому в Україні так їх мало?
І якби в мене дуже така проста мрія:
створити школу таку.
За цей час вже багато що зроблено.
З цієї мрії побудувати школу,
з якою я приїхала в Німеччину,
зараз в Луцьку вже буде перший клас, маленький, приватний.
Перший вальдорфський клас.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Інтерв'юерка
Ольга Войтович]
[Режисери
Микола Носок, Василь Гошовський]
[Режисери монтажу
Ліза Літвіненко, Дмитро Бартош]
[Оператори
Анна Савчук, Павло Пашко, Сергій Коровайний]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Катерина Акварельна, Наталія Панченко]
[Асистентки продюсерки
Ксенія Фукс, Євгенія Лисак]
[Ukraїner
Ukrainisches Atelier für Kultur und Sport]